I want to be where the bad are
up in the club and shaking my ends Chloe
Bailey's flipping her fins all the way
into the latest Tick Tock Trend lip
singing to a not safe for work version
of The Little Mermaid classic part of
your world I want to be where the people
are
I want to see you wanna see him dancing
yeah those are the lyrics we all know
from the Beloved Disney classic but over
on six act Creator Kari Cartier gave the
song a more grown-up Spin and Chloe got
in on the action you know it's
definitely more grown and sexy I want to
be where the bad are up in the
club and shaking my end listen Chloe we
don't blame you
when is that bad energy coming oh
it's coming it's already here boo
Chloe's latest Tick Tock has a special
connection her younger sister Hallie
plays Ariel in the live action remake of
the Disney classic did you find you
somebody one fan I will beat out anybody
try me
[Music]
you know I was really grateful to Rob
Marshall that he gave me the freedom to
just be me and seeing how Hallie would
sing and some of those inflections and
riffs I was allowed to do the original
music that we have is so beautiful such
a staple in all of our childhoods and
the fact that I got to tweak and edit it
a little bit was like so much fun and a
joy to have that creative freedom and
when ET spoke with Hallie at the film's
LA Premiere she said Chloe's opinion
ranks highest once I get her stamp of
approval I feel good I gotta get tissues
with me I'm so freaking proud of her
I've been seeing Billboards and
magazines of her everywhere and I am
just so freaking proud and we get to be
here now
listen I was talking to her earlier
tonight and I said this is the first
time you've done anything without having
your sister by your side how did that
feel and she said when I started it felt
like I didn't have my arm with me you
know that's how we felt because we're
literally like this and I'm just so
proud of her for believing in herself
and finding her inner strength and
taking on such an iconic role and being
so phenomenal at it so even just talking
about it I get chills to know that all
of those beautiful girls will be able to
see proper representation whether you're
black or white or anything like that
you'll be able to look at my sister and
say I can be anything that I want to be
no matter what the world tells me is
acceptable and there could not be a more
perfect area I wish I could be part of
that word
the original version or the Chloe remix
I want to be with a where the bad
are up in the club and shaking
my in the Bailey sisters can always be
part of our world